j'ai fait plus autant le fier l'un et
aux chochottes qui est cette fois un
manoir on doit le tenir jusqu'à ce que
la relève arrive
imaginez vous un peu ce bonheur
c'était un endroit important quand les
parades la 92e sont venus déloger les
nazis puis retournez au grenier tente de
les voir se pointer restera plus qu'à
s'occuper d'eux
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça un carnet qui était dans
la cave
il appartenait à un des nazis qui ont
tenu la place il parle de la famille qui
vivait là et de ce qu'ils leur ont fait
si on reste là dedans à piéger comme des
rats et vous êtes tous prêt à finir en
prison militaire
on peut pas s'en aller là y'a un truc
pas naturel tant voir et mille fois pire
que c'était quoi ça je vais dire ce à
quoi on pense tous
cette maison est hantée si tu laisses le
malade venir il reviendra de tourmenter
au centuple
rassembler le matériel et préparez vous
[Musique]
tout ce qu'on a vu depuis qu'on est là
c'est ce que les nazis au fait subir à
la famille qui vivait ici
on peut pas s'en aller ils veulent pas
nous laisser partir
c'est paris
c'est parée aile séparée elle ses
promesses
tu possède une nature très spécial nous
avons travaillé dur pour la développer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
retire mois
[Musique]
les résultats sont dans les normes
quelque chose à signaler
non non je vais bien
comment est-on bien ennuyé m
le prochain contrat est très payant
la cible est le pdg de la plus grosse
corporation aux etats unis
tu sera synchronisé à kolin tête pouvons
nous permettre aucune prête
qu'est-ce qui était aujourd'hui tu vas
dire quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si l'opposition
aux côtés des tu doit en finir
qu'est ce que tu fais je peux pas
appuyer sur la détente
j'ai besoin de savoir
j'ai besoin de savoir ce qu'elle m'a
fait
il est devenu dangereux
ouellet les victoires
[Musique]
parfois
cette petite pensée c'est tout ce qu'il
faut pour perdre le contrôle
[Musique]
c'est la première fois que vous venez
avec si oui
vous êtes recommandé par une agence
beaucoup d'établissements à ce que je
vois merci ce n'était pas un compliment
si l'angleterre et l'allemagne font
alliance depuis de nombreuses années
quelle sorte d'anglais accepterait un
poste d'enseignant à la ligue des jeunes
filles allemande des réacteurs
d'ailleurs vincent je déteste les
surprises sont les filles du haut
commandement nazi de qui dieu du
mouvement autour du col de son
angleterre pour devenir un pays très
hostile
si jamais vous êtes allemand il est
souvent difficile de savoir qui est
réellement quelqu'un qui est bon et qui
est mauvais j'ai une liste de
comploteurs massy de traître à la
couronne ce pays est en guerre avec
l'allemagne nazie ne peux l'accepter
koné fille soit capturés pouvez-vous
m'assurer qu'elles n'ont pas de soupçon
sur vous
mes étudiants ne soient pas attribués
elles sont tellement non
[Musique]
tout en noir s'est dit quelque chose
c'est le nom d'une course
personne ne l'a jamais vu je croyais que
c'était légende urbaine
mon père adoré cette fois tu le
vainqueur à flot toute l'année et qui
lui lui c'est un gars que je voulais
présenter
tu vois il a participé à la dernière
course mais ça ça suffit pas pour faire
partie de l'équipe tient à partir
d'aujourd'hui ton surnom c'est le bleu
gas gas gas joss whedon nouvelles à 2
min 20 des profits
je fais toujours ce kit chantois
j'ai perdu assez d'argent aujourd'hui la
fête ne fait que commencer
vicat la clope au bec ce qu'il leur chef
on dit qu'elle a racheté son propre
cordon ombilical avons pu échapper de
l'utérus de sa mère
sacré personnage il m'a menacé morts
d'autres des phrases
celui qui remportera le tournoi
décrochera le titre de diablo pas de
frais d'entrée l'an prochain il
empochera environ dans l'es5 fourni
c'est votre intégrité physique qui est
en jeu
tout le monde a besoin d'argent que le
monde n'est pas prêt à mourir pour
qu'une tête a dit que j'allais mourir
tout ça et y ferez quoi turc
ma soeur est très malade à elle de se
faire opérer à l'étranger il nous faut
du fric et c'est dommage que je puisse
être avec toi
bientôt on ira à vienne et la balle pour
en soigner
enfin tensions est ouest ont pris mon
père a toujours détesté perdre
[Musique]
les deux fait gaffe on n'est pas en
guerre
bienvenue en irlande il était une fois
deux fermes voisines la ferme mais
bodhum rosemary vyver est au bout du
chemin il y avait ma ferme mon fils
anthony poser ces questions solitaire
aux étoiles pourquoi m'as-tu fait ainsi
rose-marie monde donne était éperdument
amoureuse
il ya ces champs verdoyants sur cette
terre viennent un peu importe que c'est
ça me retient ici
quand il dit des choses comme celles là
mais pas dans passion moque je ressemble
à john kerry
il était aussi timbrée à la pleine lune
s'est noyé volontairement enlevé tomber
j'avais une roche attachée autour du cou
rose-marie se connaît depuis assez
longtemps maintenant voudrais tu
m'épouser
q signé les papiers pour que la ferme
soit cédé à anthony ne voit pas de lien
direct entre quoi et quoi entre moi et
toi
mon cousin risque berthod la plus belle
voiture
le but de ma bile d'aller si la ferme à
1 américaine datant d après lui
vous vous attendez après quoi moi
j'attends pas vient forcément tu devrais
venir à new york un jour anthony ne se
mariera jamais s'il faut attendre encore
je conviendrais mais ce faudrait tu te
fasses contenu complet si tôt
l'intention d'attendre après lui
veilleux connaît c'est quoi déjà eu un
rêve que tu poursuivait depuis l'enfance
et que tu n'arrivais pas à abandonner
tu as mis cette barrière entre nous on
restitue rendue heureuse ou malheureuse
tu a embrassé adam c'est lui qui m'a
embrassé c'est pour ça qu'il revient
j'ai du mal à comprendre les gens d'ici
pour rand est aussi compliqué vous
accepter des choses insensées
je n'aime pas me disputer qui aiment ça
la moitié verlande mais pas moi les
foules ircon un méchoui frame un peu
je t'envie fait confiance et que l'amour
attention et après tu te trouvais durant
combien de jours verrons-nous encore le
soleil brille et ne brille pas il brise
mois mais lieu qu'on ainsi qu'aux
[Musique]
y a pas l'air d'avoir grand monde
on veut pas faire les difficiles cefral
affaire bonsoir bienvenue à l'hôtel
normandy
bonsoir combien de nuits comptez vous
rester une nuit juste signé elle se
trouve au quatrième étage chambre 414
[Musique]
je vais prendre une douche
va te coucher est-ce que tu as perdu tu
l'as entendu
qui est cet homme devant la porte
je suis désolé je n'ai vu personne
qu'est ce qui s'est passé toute la nuit
des gens nous ont harcelé est ce que
vous me cacher quelque chose monsieur
n'ont demandé à ma femme
la bac de quoi tu parles tu es encore en
train d'aller signer qu'est ce que tu
fais
[Musique]
vous n'avez plus que huit semaines pour
préparer les auditions
gardez bien en tête que la new york
balaie l'académie ne décernera d' pour
ce cas une seule d'entre vous le corps
de danseur est un instrument il sert une
cause plus nobles la beauté idéale la
perfection le monde
la baleine échouée
c'est quoi cet endroit en fête bat
hollande ce sera toujours l'endroit
idéal pour danser et traîné un peu jaune
toi nous tue
j'aime te voir danser c'était une
première tombe ça j'avais remarqué c'est
un peu comme un courant qui émane du
ventre et qui traverse ton corps de
toutes parts et ensuite il explose en
dehors de toi c'est ça la danse
quand je fais dit papy se passe quelque
chose de différent tout s'éclaire au
moins fait hacker se ramène ils font une
audition la semaine prochaine pour
recruter du monde sur leur nouveau show
toi et moi en duo
ça ne chauffe pas
j'invite la vie je te laisserais
parcourir le monde avec un groupe de
breakdance
il est trop tard pour que je fasse
marche arrière type que je veux faire je
sais il est hors de question que je te
laisse tout envoyer promener
avec de la volonté on peut toujours
compter
[Applaudissements]
on va y arriver d'accord
[Musique]
le ballet c'est ta femme
et
comment peut-on commencer à vivre une
grande histoire d'amour
quand on sait qu'elle devra bientôt se
terminer si vous voulez que la vie soit
généreuse vous devez les mais maintenant
et de manière inconditionnelle
parce que tout peut disparaître d'un et
si c'est le cas alors combien de temps
peut-être jusqu'à noël
le procès a novel
[Musique]
je m'appelle steffi mois si steve défier
partir
elle est partie avec ce type du cirque
je vais les rattraper je prends quelques
affaires
il paraît que dans le voyage l'important
c'est la destination suis en route pour
paris et voix qui pique
mais parfois le voyage est tellement
beau qu'on en oublie la destination on
peut monter une vache comme un cheval
en italie
je sais pas si c'est les choses que
j'aime ou celle que j'ai pas pu faire
que je regretterai le plus
merci
[Musique]
pepy
ces filles soir je m'appelle steve mais
je lui retire les morceaux de verre des
fêtes
[Musique]
il a un tatouage qu'est-ce que c'était
tatoué
l'iut est vraiment sale con est mort
deux mois
c'est ton cancer non c'est la tequila
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne course
khalifa sall
vva
k
[Musique]
ouais